-Our next guest
can be seen hosting
"The Second Best Night
of Your Life"
at Union Hall in Brooklyn,
New York, October 30th.
Making their
"Tonight Show" debut,
please welcome
the very funny Sabrina Wu!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Hey, everyone.
I have some impressions
for you all. Okay.
First impression.
[ Imitates small splash ]
That was a hot girl pooping.
Second impression.
[ Raises, lowers voice ]
That was the economy.
That's all I know about it.
Okay, last impression.
[ Beat-boxing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Stop, stop. Stop.
That was nothing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I grew up in Michigan,
where they made us read
this widely taught, critically
acclaimed children's book
"Tikki Tikki Tembo."
First page, it goes, "There once
was a Chinese boy named
Tikki Tikki Tembo-no Sa Rembo
Chari Bari Ruchi-pip Peri Pembo.
No, there wasn't.
I have a Chinese brother.
His name is Kevin.
And, actually,
can we do an experiment?
Group experiment.
I'm going to say real Chinese.
And then, at some point,
I'm going to switch to
not quite Chinese,
but I won't tell you when.
You tell me when.
Cool.
[ Speaking Chinese ]
Tikki Tikki Tembo-no Sa Rembo
Chari Bari Ruchi-pip Peri Pembo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow. Wow.
You know, I've told
that joke a million times.
You are the first group
that has gotten it.
No, obviously not.
So, growing up,
I had this complex,
this inferiority complex,
where I was like,
"Oh, my God, oh, my God.
I'll do anything
to make a white person like me."
I learned all this --
I learned how to beat-box. Why?
Why do I know how to do this?
13 years old, I could do this.
Honestly, I was training
for Bar Mitzvahs.
One time, I was in a closeted,
label-less relationship
with this white woman,
who, a year in, was like,
"I love you so much.
You mean the world to me.
Do you want to be
my squirrel-friend?"
She said "squirrel-friend"
'cause "girlfriend"
was too scary.
And I, instead of being like,
"We're done," I went...
[ Chuckles, clicking tongue ]
So, yeah, I don't have always
a ton of gay pride, okay?
I realized a year and a half ago
that I was trans,
and I was like,
"What do you mean some people
don't have to be gay at all,
and I have to be gay twice?
I have to come out to
my nervous, immigrant
parents again?
I was like,
"Hey, Dad, I'm trans."
And my dad went,
"Well, I'm driving!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, honestly, I always
suspected he might be a driver.
At some point I was like,
"So, you know,
I'm thinking about going on 'T,'
taking testosterone."
And my dad was like, "Okay,
you don't like your body?
Well, do you think
I like my face?
Do you think I like my skin,
my eyes?"
He kept going.
I had to pause coming out to be
like, "No, Dad, don't be sad.
You're so sexy."
So, yeah, I, like,
really need a win.
I really need one.
I'm in the
most humiliating rivalry.
When I was in college, I took a
cute little storytelling class.
And one day,
we went to Moth StorySLAM,
and I went up and did terrible.
And then this girl from my class
went up, won the whole thing.
And everyone was like,
"Oh, my God.
She's going to be famous.
She's such a good performer."
And I literally said,
"I'm the one
who's going to be famous.
I'm the good performer."
It's been six and a half years,
and I'm...
Look, the "Tonight Show"
is a huge honor.
I'm so happy to be here.
So, it's just that
that girl is literally
inaugural Youth Poet Laureate
Amanda Gorman.
If you don't remember,
she performed poetry
at Biden's inauguration.
People sort of say
she united the country.
Michelle Obama
said she changed her life.
She's been on
the cover of "Vogue."
She's hosted the Met Gala.
She's a "New York Times"
best seller.
If she becomes a staff writer on
"Big Mouth," I will die.
Did you know that she's running
for president in 2036?
I'm going to have to
vote for her.
And I thought,
you know, in college,
maybe she was
a little overconfident,
because she would
literally say like,
"You know, one day,
I might be, like,
the first
black woman president."
When I was in college,
my big dream -- I was like,
"Maybe one day I could be, like,
an Asian Jack Black."
I'm Sabrina Wu.
Thank you so much!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-One day. Maybe one day.
That was so good.
Sabrina Wu!
[ Cheers and applause ]
See Sabrina October 30th
at Union Hall
in Brooklyn, New York.
We'll be right back, everybody.